oh you can't
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
what's up everybody dope is yola here
hope you have a dope ass day welcome
back to
the dope as usual podcast we're here to
talk about life drugs problems
accomplishments
everything in between today we have
fabian alamour actor pro skater
thank you for showing up thank you for
coming thank you for having me man i
like you put them back on yeah put them
back on
you know i put them back on because i
want to introduce myself as the
tolo tonero that's good introduce
yourself so everybody and i just did
active skater
how how do you come when people ask what
do you do what do you what do you say i
just say
i'm all i'm a person of many talents my
boy you know what i'm saying and
there's a lot more that i haven't even
showed yet you know
i i've survived prison you know what i'm
saying i survived being a drug addict
i survived fights sell fights
um all the all the little nonsense on
the streets you know what i mean i don't
let nothing like
phase me i try not to and and i survived
the reggaetonero classes
i i gotta thank my boy rachael for
inviting me here you know yes yes thank
you dude thank you
he uh he actually brought um drawn on
too
oh yeah jerome yeah that was cool as
hell man man jaron
wilson is that's my boy dubs e dubs yeah
that's he's sick man jess j
dub man he's a sick ass skater he's
still doing it too he's still skating
i just seen something recently him and
guy like just killing it on the
skateboard
dude everybody's got kids yeah i know
right everybody's got kids it's a little
different
i had my kids before them so my kids
like because my kids
yeah i started way before them because
you know latinos go in hard and quick 15
to 16.
you're at 15 if you don't have a kid
you're tripping yeah what's wrong with
you
same that's what i've always got my
whole life too i have no kids you got to
have a baby at 15 if you're a real
latino
you'll have a baby at 15 if not you're
you're whitewashed what's something
wrong with you
get out of here yeah same here man move
to the west side
well the west where i'm from is the
ghetto oh no but you're talking about
the likes
down westwood oh west of l.a
now the west side right where i'm at is
bad too how many yeah i grew up in echo
park
oh right down this oh because when i
first moved here i moved uh
right down figaro and sunset you know
where it kind of meets up by the freeway
figaro now that's all bougie it's all
nice they got these big buildings before
that's where i lived
that's right it wasn't like that before
though oh i've seen all the pictures my
grandma my family's from here right by
dodger stadium yeah
so that's by that big chili on the
corner there's like a famous chili's
they used to be this like chili uh spot
on the corner of
of am i am i right it's right there on
um
sunset am i thinking fig or grand
there's like a big boulder or something
there's like a big uh
chili spot it was real famous everybody
used to go line up there no i've never
seen it they were in competition with
tommy's they so
hey man diarrhea 24 7. you know hey
tommy's the first man yo it's la right
and i felt terrible the next day sorry
tommy's
not tommy's just it's just like tommy's
a my [ __ ] just flows now homer
you know you just know what thomas i'm
gonna be sick in a couple minutes it'll
make you good it'll make you regular
you know what i'm saying it'll make you
regular if you if you have a constipated
yeah if that's a natural laxative like
just eat a tommy's burger the next day
you're guaranteed
to get it all out you know what i'm
saying disagree with you man at all
yeah i don't you grew up by echo park
then yeah that's born and raised that's
what my friend my
uncle and everybody grew up around they
just told me like it used to be crazy
out there when i was a kid
yeah yeah yeah cause uh when i moved
there's just couples and swans
couples swans no couples in those kinds
of stuff and on the swan boats
yeah that's all i see i was gonna say
now i've never seen those swans there
i've seen some that's against
those ducks and like some some goose
that we're tripping out like they used
to rush us yeah they do
i have a video of them dude the geese
goose whatever you say they used to run
up on us like i used to go there with my
son
and try to like or go there and they
would one that one will just
make eye contact with you and i'll chase
you i flack in your ass right
like you don't want to smack a duck you
feel weird but i'll speak the [ __ ] out
of duck yeah i'll kick a duck i will
i'll kick a goose too i don't give a
damn i'm not letting nothing bite me
no she had some crazy lotus disease
there
i mean they got the lotus festival right
there bro i'm not letting nobody i don't
give a [ __ ] what it is like i'm not
really i'm not into getting hit
yeah i'm saying by nobody no so i mean
if you're trying to hit me like i don't
even like my nephews and nieces
stepping on my shoes and playing crazy
with me i have to get them and wrap them
up and put them in a little pretzel real
quick
hey man these shoes are new food stuff
play with me you know
but like you know like it's it's cool
but in a friendly way but kind of
letting them feel the muscle you know oh
of course my i have little brothers and
sisters so they know
you can't [ __ ] with me no especially the
hair dude come on oh this is only when
i'm on on camera man
only for everything so what it just like
hangs like tony hawk
after that or what what do you do like
you does that thing that's stiff right
now right it's stiff
it's hard yeah i probably could go like
that and you'll go
that [ __ ] about an hour hour
kind of okay at about hour two that [ __ ]
is one one entity that should
not move yeah he could be like hair in
the wind hell no it's like a statue in
the exactly yeah
nah when i get i don't know man ever
since i started doing my hair on camera
i'm like
yeah you got to be proper i got to look
perfect yeah so yeah look at me man i
try to look this is as perfect as you
can oh you were way more proper than i
do i came all done i came up with the
like you know i had to go
last night hard and get all the little
trimmings and it's like
it's like the mexican comes out of me i
bring out the scissors and i start doing
busch gardening right here i'm like
are you at the age that you wear those
uh brown sandals or socks
what you know what i'm saying like when
dudes get past like 30 they start
wearing those brown
sandals with no socks my dad wears them
oh hey whoa whoa whoa my brother's
wearing them
hell no hold on first of all good you
aren't there yet first of all i'll never
be there homie look
good i'm i still got prison rules in my
head
like i don't walk out the house with
slippers
or bears might have to run i still take
a shower with my chunk glass homie oh
[ __ ] like i do
laundry in in the shower you know what
i'm saying jesus
and i'm i wake up and i bust down and
it's chow time you know what i'm saying
i still got regulars that's right it's
like it's like a
military life it's it's more than
military it's
prison regulars you know rules and if
you don't follow them
you know what time it is i'm not in that
world whatsoever
hey i'm not me neither no more thank you
but i'm just i got you though
i know all about it i know you're about
to bust down demi burpees right now i
know everything
i know all that [ __ ] i know sucks i know
you know what a burpee is it's not
well no i don't know if you can get down
push it down yeah oh you do those in
football
yeah i play sports when you play
football no one i used to yeah you said
what's your please
suck center nose tackle
center center no stock guy that hikes
and then there's something where's that
that guy that the quarterback had his
hands right under your wibbles like that
hated it bro
so you had a long right underneath did
you have a bond was that bonding time
like you did each other bro
you guys hated each other during the
game because he went hard no he punched
me sometimes
and the balls yes like because he didn't
like me i like him it's like
i can't stop we're in the middle of a
game but after this and you can't talk
you can't look back at him because it
makes it more sexy
because if you look back and i'll be
like i'm a bit stupid you know
like you're like he's like what i know
you like it it was it was
it got hard it was hard to get used to
man it really was that hard did you just
say it got hard
here wait it was hard to get yourself
it got harder it was hard to get you i
mean difficult to get used to football
players be slapping each other on the
buns
i didn't [ __ ] that you got it you didn't
do that
i was so you hadn't been slapping
everybody's school over there nah nah i
just did better than everybody
bro that's why you got fired that's why
you didn't see
that's why you didn't make that he was
they gonna stick you right there and
he's gonna he's gonna always be the nose
tackle right there they wanna be the
hiker get him to be the hiker because
they want to touch his wig
my whole family just showed up for this
interview today hey dog hey
hey time to reveal the truth thank you
no i'm joking
did you play sports i did once i played
sports what'd you play when i was
growing up i played everything i played
um
we played freeze tag baby gun fights uh
ghetto sports
you know like we played like um like
did you play anyways we played that
willie's just oh we our game of chess
was like this yeah open chest our game
of chess started like this
go ahead fool oh that's as hard as you
hit me it's hard like hell no so that's
how we play chess
and then bam and then you go get your
money back you know oh yeah bb gun
fights let's
fight i remember rock fights rock fights
i remember that too it was fun man
another game we played uh it's just the
name i didn't give it the name but it's
called smear the queer
oh that's backwards yeah that's like get
against the wall and you just now you
can't say it
it was like yeah but it was called smear
yeah and i remember i didn't like you
running i didn't make the name but
that's what we played and until i got
older i was like dude let's not call
this that's not call let's play football
just play
throw the ball at the guy against the
wall and hit his ass up
with the suicide yeah that's what you
used to call it suicide suicide man that
game
yeah dodge ball but with the hard ball
bro like it's almost like a bowling ball
the dodge ball would kill you dodge ball
it wasn't it was like a hard hard ball
that doesn't sound like fun nah it kind
of hurts yourself yeah
with no shirts if you play a game if you
miss the free throw or you just shoot if
you miss it everybody starts
beating the [ __ ] out of you until you go
and touch the pole that game sucks
how about a game where like you just get
beat up for no reason for just saying
the wrong thing
you mean life in the wrong neighborhood
growing
around the wrong neighborhood yeah and
the wrong uncles they're from a certain
gang and they just like
take it out on you that's why when
people is you don't do fear factor stuff
like scary stuff like bro walk through
where i'm from yeah with blue or red and
then see how long you made it
the fear factor was like just stepping
outside the house my boyfriend
was filming true we weren't eating that
thing but we was running
[ __ ] that's why i look like this and
talk like this because i'm affiliated i
ain't trying to get in your back
and now you're just a crack crime
fighter with that hair there it is
that's right
because you look like you look like hey
if i saw you i'm not even lying
if we wasn't here and i just saw you
walking down the street a little 21 jump
ish you know what i'm saying but like
you could have that feel like you could
pull out a badge and arrest the
[ __ ] and i'll be like the best
look to have though that yeah it is
because it's i used to have helicopters
because then you could do those 100 000
bags
and make those deals and get away with
it looking like of course that's why i
always look
pleasant i always look good that's so
funny you say that because i
always describe it as pleasantville yeah
that's right clark kent
clark kentville where's lois bro what's
up with her
that was like 75 now isn't she what
actress used to play her
she was taught teri hatcher terry
hatchet this bottle said terry hatchet
that's from [ __ ]
sex in the city with those high notes
dogs that's all totally different
terry hatchet no that's not another
thing who used to back
that oh yeah you have the internet yeah
we'll just do that look
the real no it is terry hatcher oh [ __ ]
it was frightening wait you were right
no but that's that way you're talking to
original no i'm not talking about rich
i'm talking about okay so you went
with the slick hair in the 90s and [ __ ]
then i grew up see look
well now we're talking two different
grown-ups like okay you grew up
in the 90s i grew up in the 80s and
it wasn't originally that girl right
there it was her
oh yeah yeah lois lane margaret kimberly
margot
kidder yeah and she died holmes yeah so
did that
original superman too that's a trip oh
yeah horseback rating
i mean he was paralyzed but he was
already yeah that's it's crazy as [ __ ]
hey so how long you had this show man
dope as usual 12 weeks exactly
today yeah yeah so i'm here on
anniversary yeah three months
three months in yeah perfect oh that's
cool
yeah i know see i like you already we
got off topic so fast man i love doing
that [ __ ]
my brain just misfired you grew up an
echo park
that's where we started this from oh
yeah you keep going
yeah so echo park and so what was it
like growing up there because i remember
like you even said it was a little wild
over there well yeah it was
it was a long time ago back when it
wasn't so gentrified
you know now that the ducks are all
straight and square they don't rush you
know coffee shops excuse me can i pass
through here
everything's like hey but wait hold on
not too long ago there was some
big time homeless coved i saw it the
other day
tense yeah it was bad i wouldn't drop
food off to some of those fools there
was a couch
a bed and a tv in one of these guys huge
tents he was living like a [ __ ]
college student better than a college
dude i couldn't believe that [ __ ]
bro some of them guys were just okay so
this is what i found out and inside
scoop from the
bum nation they was doing this
some of the original guys that got there
that claimed to be
homeless and they were doing the you
know bomb [ __ ]
and they was hanging out on the tents
there were other dudes that they were
charging and taxing
like hey this is barter town like
you know this is our town and we go
charge you rent now for
setting up your tent and they were going
around taxing fools
hey what don't i'm just a messenger
that's crazy though i mean if i'm
homeless i don't even know where you're
[ __ ] right how do you got what are
you gonna pay with cans
you might as well go to work what are
you giving dog like that's crazy
[ __ ] though yeah they were just good
they were taxing they were just being
like real crazy with it so i'm glad they
shut it down because that park
when i grew up at that park i i didn't
grow up with all that crazy
nonsense going on like these fools were
raping and robbing and stabbing fools on
one side of the park
and by the boathouse you couldn't even
go and kick it there because
it was just too like dirty and bad you
know for real like skid row but yeah
park yeah and i'm glad they got them out
because now it's it's going to be a park
again
you know and and a lot of them fools
i'll be honest with you they if they
really wanted help
in my book if you really really want
help
you can go and there's there's there's
places there's programs there's things
that there's you know a lot of them are
fully healthy
there's there's nothing wrong with them
they don't got no mental disabilities or
nothing but like those who do
okay yes there's maybe those are the
special ones but
there's a small portion of them the rest
of them we're just taking advantage of
this covet
vacation you know i think that's uh i
mean i've said exactly what you said
before like if you want help there's
help you're not just going to starve
around on the streets there's programs
you can go into a shelter but you've got
to be clean and you've got to be there
by six clients
they don't want it they want to sell
drugs sorry for them
they want to make money and do all this
stuff bro like they're using the covert
as an excuse to make
ends meet with like let's set up a tent
and sell dope out of here that's crazy
yeah man then again if you're kind of a
low life that yeah it's a good thing you
got going i mean if you only need 50
bucks a day
type of [ __ ] like don't get me wrong
though i'm all for feeding the homeless
and helping out for sure i've been there
myself
but you know i that was a choice for me
because there was a well it was a choice
but it was because i was using drugs and
it was all up to me to stop there was
family that was offering me help
and there was friends but i chose to go
on a there's a moderate goal
and a crazy run how it works though yeah
so there's always an a or someone like
no you can live here and then you
someone steals and it's over
that's how a lot of family [ __ ] happens
like that right i got something and i
got
like i had crazy influences growing up
so
growing up who are you looking up to as
a kid in this
who else you look up to your father
right you look up to your father your
uncles
and your mom and everybody and your
aunts
was there setting good samples for you
or not no
they tried they tried to but the only
the only way they knew how was because
they had me young so of course they were
setting bad examples because they didn't
know any better themselves
because they grew up in that recidivism
of jail and drugs and gangs and and
that's all that was there
of course people had jobs and [ __ ] but
it was really
um how could you say it's just the
neverending cycle
the setting homie it's the setting of
how we are and how we
that's all we know and growing up so the
parents
without even knowing it they're
influencing and teaching the kids
like always i was just absorbing all
that and so was my brothers and sisters
and my uncles and you just because it
becomes it's a celestia
and you just you grow into it hey and
that's how you
and you you that's what you know so when
you go to school and you see other
people
that's when you realize and i was
surrounded and i went to virgil by the
way i went to virgil junior high
i went to i got kicked out of virgil for
doing these
and fighting and then and then um i went
to
sent out of the oh after you get
suspended so many times they kick you
out of the whole l.a district
so i went to i went to crenshaw they
sent me the crenshaw
all the way the [ __ ] out yeah way out
there in um uh
mount vernon now it's johnny cochran but
it was mount vernon uh junior high
wow and and back then it was like
all blood school [ __ ] it was bad so here
i am from dodger stadium i'm wearing all
kinds of dodgers
blue and gray they're like looking at me
up and down like
what's up with them blue pants and blue
shirt and blue hat and
yeah take off them laces and i was just
like what
and it was it was bad see that i mean i
grew up in town just like that but i
i was talking about my mom used to beat
the [ __ ] out of me to avoid all that
[ __ ]
nice and uh my dad tried to be a gang
member for like four years and it was
the weirdest [ __ ] cuz he's hella nice
it doesn't it didn't work yeah my dad
might it didn't it didn't work but
they had me at 16 18. he he he
he was a part-time like weekend warrior
then like he tried it and then he didn't
like it he got out
it's just the people who's hanging out
my name is shoot crank and [ __ ] like
and so with people he was hanging i just
noticed one day he was on all red
and he had a shaved hand i go dad what
are you doing with this little
strip of hair you got to stop this [ __ ]
what area of did you grow up in brazil
was all red
merced california set up no oh [ __ ] oh
you come out there that's why i'm saying
like
wearing blue over there you get shot
when red over here it's the same thing
so when i moved here i got to wear a
blue shirt for the first time my life
okay okay so it's my favorite color and
it's like oh i'm in l.a maybe i won't
get [ __ ] hit up because i hate fools
hitting me up
when they know i'm not affiliated look
at me i say dude 60 times don't hit me
i hate that [ __ ] well there's a lot of
gangsters that say dude now so you got
to be
but you know if you go are you from dude
you know i get that i get that but you
can hear me talk like a [ __ ] white
guy maybe like this but they'd be mixing
it right
like hey doody where you from me dude
chocolate food dude that's a whole
nother job
but they're wearing vans and they're
trying to gang bang on a skateboard and
you know what i mean like yeah yeah it's
cool like i think i think it's good that
i i think maybe i don't know it's safe
to say maybe i
i started dressing like that back in the
day good thing and i look the way i look
and grew up like that i but i was
sponsored
as a skateboarder i turned i got into
skateboarding like on
just that was my question how did you
get into this if you're from echo park
and just from me to you like you know
you growing up there's not a lot of
brown
skate kids like i was one of the few
fools skating
and everybody else is white everybody
only [ __ ] brown kid was fat i was
trying to do these little rails and
yeah it's just it's different you almost
it's almost like uh
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] why are you
chilling with those white kids no i'm
skating they just happen to like this
sport too
[ __ ] like it's fun try it so how
did you get into that
i was trying to do a rail that's funny
for real it was man my whole life i
would have loved to see that
balancing on the rail boy on the rail
nice
that's cool but i've seen it before i've
seen it done you know like this full
smoke escape too
i know i've seen it like i said i've
seen it before yeah yeah yeah
it's no joke so um how did you get into
skating if you're in this
your family's not into skating and
they're obviously not leading you that
way yeah they weren't throwing no
skateboards at me even though my dad
stole the skateboard and gave it to me
or found one i think a
a purple veraflex board back in the day
when it was like
clear purple veraflex it was dope
it was cool but i didn't i was like i
got on my knees with it and just tell
you
you know yeah and then i just pushed it
to the side years later
you know i went through all these little
phases of the bb gun phase
the bikes and then the and then one day
it was like we were hanging on the block
and i just seen
you know me and my boy juan we were like
we saw we heard a bunch of awling you
know the sound of aling like
we were like what the hell is that you
know so
i said hey lower lower the weekends are
made for fun
right now lower that music can you lower
weekends are made for fun
i hear some noise coming down the street
or you're in your house
and then they just lord it and i'm like
it was kids awling
and we're like no we're we're in the
front of the house with the with the
ford courier truck my boy
my homeboy's um brother rest in peace
hector
and mondo you know hector rest in peace
but they're all brothers juan hector and
mondo and
they all we i used to kick it with them
every day and they had a truck
that we all stole parts for oh [ __ ] to
build
the to vulture on it to make it you know
what it was it was like a dope
and he bought some [ __ ] but we all stole
parts too we all participated and like i
had a lot of crackhead friends
so they would still ship that was that
was easiest stereos because they all
like stole stuff from my dad and they
all like you know
we used to sell out of our house dope so
everybody want to go and bring them
stolen [ __ ]
oh so you grew up in that like where
you're i grew up in a house where like a
party house in the 80s were
cracking pcp and drinking and weed and
gangs it was like the headquarters right
you're just in your room
and guess what right by tommy's homie
right by tommy's right i know exactly
what
we heard in it
all night every day all the time that's
my dad's house
girls would come from tommy's three at a
time
when mini skirts the mini falla to come
and piss
and i'd be like looking out my window
oh you know what i'm saying that i'm a
little boy don't judge me i'm a little
boy that's how i got started
don't judge me that's funny as [ __ ] yeah
don't [ __ ] dare judge me with that
haircut
yeah you know what i'm saying that's how
i became a man
tommy to help me
[Music]
what yo my dad's house had that
everybody would tag on the walls in one
room and all the gang [ __ ] would be on
one wall
and the whole i remember that [ __ ] when
we painted over it that day man that's
my dad's house party
yeah everyone when you're done with the
bar
heads jumping music thank you
i was just like oh [ __ ] that song
whenever i hear today i'm just like
i just want to go down gives me
flashbacks like
i'll be over there dancing car music
this pulls out a car
show goes to the bathroom i go to the
bathroom and sneak a jerk
no i'm joking by the way i coined that
phrase sneaker jerk
in jail the sneaker jerk you don't jerk
on
and just open public domains you don't
do public domains homie
you do sneaker jerks because if the
homies catch you jerking homie it's over
think i'm playing try it try it right
now in front of me see what happens
i you know what i think if you were
anywhere and you did that you could get
sucked
someone's gonna hit you yeah you get
sucked out yeah someone's got it i
sometimes have to suck myself up
you know what i'm saying take it one
hand punch myself yeah regulate myself
for doing what i just did
oh god no not
no but hey but anyway back to tommy's
yeah yeah yeah yeah skateboard slappy
turned it down there there you know i'm
hearing the noise
i'm hearing the noise and i'm and we go
over there and and um
these asian kids is skating
and and fast forward man like we
we they didn't want to lend us the
boards you have to borrow the board yeah
and back in the 80s it was expensive
they weren't jimmy z's like you know the
velcro jimmy z's i don't know if anybody
remembers that you guys are like barely
born a few years ago but
but anyway there were some pants called
jimmy z's and stucy and
they're like oh i've heard of that yeah
right um
the store i'm saying yeah like it's an
old ass store everybody was trying to
get sponsored by that back in my day
okay
it's a brand i know what it is yeah and
um anyway so that was like
the sponsor to get into back then and
vision street wear was the shoe and air
walk
vans was always around but air walks in
vision street wearing vans were like the
main main shoe
vans probably number one tony hawk
brought air walk and mark gonzalez
brought vision streetwear
so i got down the line i would be turned
pro
by mark gonzalez oh no [ __ ] yeah mark
inside you know who marcus one of the
first skaters i really started with my
friend ryan all of them are white dudes
they all have the tapes they all have
the [ __ ] uh
the dvds and all the skate videos i
remember mark gonzales my homie ryan was
like look at this fool looking for
these stairs and that's the first time i
really saw skate video and i remember
watching like this is [ __ ] incredible
and then i got stuck on it
that's how i got into this game and it
still did motivate you to keep skating
i stopped about 14. i got into drugs you
got into drugs nice that's a good that's
a good
like okay that will do it because drugs
will take anybody yeah
yeah skating was done with me yeah it
touched me
it got me while i was skating and like
you know after the transition of
getting sponsored like i stole my first
board i went to like
not too far from here glendale eagle
rock i went there down there to go
steal my first board and then oh after
those kids didn't let you borrow it you
wouldn't
yeah because they said it was expensive
and they told me the price and i was
like damn that ain't never gonna happen
my mom ain't ever gonna buy me them
shoes yeah that skateboard hell no i
so i start doing run outs on and i start
like clotheslining kids
and taking their boards first we would
go to a donut shop and take
like there was this donut shop that it
was like they were just practically
giving it away bro they're leaving at
the front
they're practically giving it away yeah
they never do they're leaving it outside
in their inside plane
so they got to come around and open the
door and i'm just i passed by with my
homie and we just grabbed like four or
five at a time and just
dude we're gone getting back to the ford
courier truck and jumping music
you know what i'm saying yeah to to his
weekend were made for fun homie
and that's where the weekends are made
for fun for us we stole boards
and then we came back and we tried to
skate with our regular shoes on
with our cortez and our converse and
cortez are the worst our corduroy pants
and
little we're trying to skate and like
hold on to a wall of ollie homes like
hey try to do it hey try to do it you
should do it next time
try the ollie fool you don't know how to
ollie dick nigh not ollie dick
watch fool hold on to the wall dick
watch and then you hold on to the waffle
and then you go like that and then you
you know so we eventually taught each
other like
that's not an ollie dick this is how you
do it full so we became competitive with
each other so let's try
to teach it because we are very
competitive like i used to
i used to fight a lot like you know i'm
very competitive on me like
i don't like to lose for [ __ ] you know
yeah once you start getting it and then
you realize oh [ __ ] i'm actually yeah
i'm actually good then that's it and
then my friend became better than me and
i was like
it's only because i like to party
weekends were made for you know i kept
that real
yeah i stood with that and i jump in
music every weekend i'd go take and he'd
be stay skating skating skating and then
i'd come back and he'd have like
like five or ten new tricks [ __ ] i'd be
like but at least i scammed on like five
different chicks
you got five tricks but i got five
chicks fool you you know
what do you mean yeah scammed on them
like lengua you know whatever you know
oh that's you
know what's up with this guy homie you
don't know the term scammy
yeah i know this were scammy i've never
heard what's up
you never scammed on no one at ditching
party fool what the [ __ ] does that mean
what the f hey you never leave you never
made out with nobody at a ditching party
i mean a girl
wait a ditching party a ditching party
you never had a dick you mean where you
just leave school it's vatho too he
looks
wow hey that's benjamin button over
there
hey a ditching party no it's called sell
drugs and not go to school i make money
i didn't care about girls i was trying
to make money more life
so that's my scamming party was uh sell
drugs to all the kids that ditched
well damn no wonder you got a podcast
food you've been saving money all your
whole life i've been [ __ ] trying to
make money
as a child man but you know when i
ditched so i guess i'm getting paid for
this hell no all right
jump in music no
yeah you you should stitch and just
don't change the subject am i getting
paid for this or what i'm doing
you paid two high fives too high super
hard
yeah two bags homie hey look hey look
hey so yeah i i ended up going to like a
lot of those
parties you know and um
that's how it is man you you know back
then
we we skated and were you or you were
involved in gangs there was not too much
going on we didn't have like
cell phones bro you know no no there was
there was not even pagers back then
we were just this is before the pager
came out
i'm talking the 80s not the 90s homie
where you know the crack epidemic was
like in full effect
and especially at my house you know what
i'm saying they're selling it yeah they
make them
we wake up on the floor and think it's
like oh look at this marshmallow oh no
it's a rock [ __ ]
that's 40 bucks a rock that 40 bucks my
ass says [ __ ] that probably worth like
like 100
something for real yeah big old big ol
pierre bro
like big noggins and little ones and you
know it was everywhere i used to carry a
lot of money like this and stash it for
my mom and dad
oh [ __ ] were you taking [ __ ] and selling
it for that of course
okay i'll say if you're not [ __ ]
tripping i would have been doing this
taking a couple dollars here and there
too
and like just just you know that's how
it was but we were up and down up and
down because mom and dad used you know
so it's like it's
you know so it's like it's not just like
they were concentrating like you
with the clark kent haircut on money no
they was doing drugs too they're from
the hood food they were doing some
crazy [ __ ] they wasn't just
concentrating on the dough which they
should have been but they did it
so yeah and i never [ __ ] a crack i only
smoke crack like once once or twice it's
just nasty you never smoke crack
once or twice because i don't like it
it's just nasty as [ __ ] once or twice
wait we said he'd never smoke crackers i
only did it once or once or twice
now how many times did you do it i'd
never [ __ ] with crackling you never
[ __ ]
never fight never look i never [ __ ]
with crack i only smoked
it once or twice yeah [ __ ] way it's
like yo i do it actively
because i [ __ ] with it that's what i'm
saying hold on dog
either you when when you smoke crack
you're not just gonna smoke it one time
and then
and then sit back and not think about it
15
10 minutes later you're you're gonna
want another hit i didn't i hit it i
hated it right off the bat i mean my
head [ __ ] hurt
you smoked it once or twice yeah i know
but it wasn't like i
got crack in one sitting or different
sessions well the first time i ever
smoked it
oh my gosh there's more than one time
and one time there's
not one time okay two times and once
okay so
i might have seen him on a crack run
juice out there two times you were the
little kid the little chubby kid trying
to
i was holding your hair on the
skateboard doing rails on christmas
fool's hair when i was a kid oh yeah you
had long hair like
over there yeah nah said oh i can't see
you like that
i look a lot different man yeah i'm
trying to look like i'm hey pay me
netflix
that's right why don't you pay him he
could pay me yeah i'll keep coming with
all this hey look clark can't but that's
fine give me a check yeah give give him
a check and he'll give me a check
gillette what's up gillette hello red
bull
oh there let's pay come on adidas we're
on this
let's get lock what's in my name we're
on this [ __ ] yeah different different
path man you're on your acting [ __ ]
right now i'm like acting [ __ ]
right now the height is [ __ ] how did you
get into that how did i get into that
because you didn't go like you know i
want to be a [ __ ] actor you don't
want to know something
it started a long ass time ago the
the real real real a long time ago my
friend wilbur or bina
he's a professional break dancer damn
he used to skate for sir fetish world
industries
he looked like christian josoy but he
was salvadorian
big buff he could do any ho ho he had
long hair
he had that apocalypto nose he had that
he had that
face like he looked like like no he
looked like the dad like you know that
the crazy dad
he looked like him damn a good ass movie
yeah
the one that's on mayans now he's on
mayans
i haven't seen that yet oh come on homie
you're sitting here right here come on
hey
give him a fresh one okay do you want a
fresh one or what they say
you want the four or the five homie the
four of the five
pick one yo you said that [ __ ] multiple
times you want a four or a five
yeah you said that you often
i do say that often homie i coined that
too
go to pelican bay they know what the
four of the five is that's
nah i'm good he's like i'm good i'm cool
maybe some outreach program
i'm trying to do that i'm trying to go
back with arc the anti-recidivism
coalition
founded by scott budnik he's started a
big
organization and um scott budnick is
huge man like he's done like a lot of
movies he's the
executive producer for like the hangover
oh good
all the franchise of the hangover um
scott nick has done
just mercy old school like that dude's
done amazing stuff that's uh what's
what's the film company you work with
penne they made that movie yeah that's
who he works with too now
nice so good [ __ ] yeah yeah well so he
started the outfit started
he started a an organization program
called
anti-recidivism coalition arc
and it's about just getting the inmates
that are
locked up get ready for the streets and
to like
to for mass incarceration in california
like to start getting them
to the their minds ready for like
to be productive on the streets and
there's curriculum in there like
a lot of the stuff is just to prepare
you for the society
and and to get you like to get you a
trade and to help you get going and get
education
it's all about the the way you think you
know the way we process stuff
and like that's how it all starts for me
i think it all starts with the process
of because you could say something to me
and and
and i can either process it in a bad way
or in a good way so it's just
made to help that that program has
helped me
like the way i think the way i the way i
just move now and the way i talk and act
and
good like you know it's just in in a
positive way because
before i would take things so like
personal when it shouldn't have been
personal yeah or
or like you know um things like uh
like how i saw society
so now i got a a whole new look and a
different
perspective of things you know it's good
though man most people don't get that
when they come out yeah
go right the [ __ ] back yeah i love i
love scott
and i love what he's done and like he
can explain it way better but
i've done the program and um i'm gonna
be working with them pretty soon
and uh arc is huge bro and they're just
getting bigger so i would like to you
know i'm glad that you
you know let's tie that up yeah that's
good man and and
and sam lewis is the director and he's
doing an amazing job
of you know getting it out there i seen
him on the news the other day talking
about it
and they got like they could get you
into the fire department
while you're incarcerated my friend is
so you can come out and have a career
it's real you can you can not just that
you can
go out come out and just teach like i
got a another friend
um josh swindell who was the ex
professional skateboarder as well he
went in for a murder he got in a bar
fight and killed the dude with his you
know bare hands and uh
he ended up getting locked up he did
like 20 years
damn he came out he came out and now
he's like
he's doing amazing stuff man he's been
sober the main thing is just like
being sober and staying clean
[Music]
and and being productive yeah
introduction is the
the main thing once you protect you you
feel like you're worth it and [ __ ] yeah
because once your head is
on right everything else is going to
just flow in
and just the pieces all make sense of
the puzzle you know and a lot of people
that end up in jail are on drugs they
don't think
very highly of themselves as you know
people in the earth they're just like no
i do this this
i can never teach class like no you
[ __ ] can't just
start working to be surprised like
there's so much
negativity and and and just uh
just uh you know there's a lot of it's a
it's a place
filled with envy and hate and jealousy
and
and and um you know everybody it's like
the i like to
i like to say it's like the devil's
backyard man it's like prisons are
but but there's a there's a handful of
people now
that are have given the opportunity and
given the right programs and the right
skill
minds mindset with the skills involved
in it you can turn it around
and you could come home after being a
lifer and being good
and doing the the necessary programs and
the right curriculum in there
you could you have a chance of coming
home now so
now it's up to you yeah as an individual
being locked up how you want to you want
to do your times
you got a chance to come home homie if
you want to you know it's just up to you
like it's a good way to i mean you
you're there you're already there and
you're hitting your head and most
like i said most people aren't so that's
that that is what pretty much got you
the arc program
yeah yeah i joined it in pelican bay and
um
and i'm still with them nice and and
acting
huh is that how you started looking at
acting differently no well i've always
i i started acting like i tell you in in
88
in 1988 i did my first acting ever
i i'm gonna be honest with you you want
to keep it 100 homie i've been acting
all my life
because even when i didn't want to stab
that kid in this in the second grade
with the pencil
i was acting like i was tough yeah but i
i
you know i was doing it because i was my
father wanted me to exactly my father
wanted me to
and he said go you know don't let nobody
you ain't gonna be no punk don't let
nobody take your money so you go and
so i had to act like and i and i lied to
him and
had a whole fabricated story and told my
father that i did
but i really didn't [ __ ] and i seen how
he embraced me so i said
i gotta go do more so now i gotta do it
and then when i did it
he embraced it he embraced it and then
that made it then
okay for me that's not your fault hey
man you're looking up to somebody you
look at i'm just looking
fools [ __ ] i said whenever they get mad
at me or they obviously start tripping
on me
and like pops he's cool with it but it's
it's it's just it's not his fault though
because
maybe maybe he that's how he was brought
up and that's how he was raised and
you know but like you you it's a turning
point not everybody gets it you got it
and goes you know what
i gotta start thinking more positive and
stop taking anything so personal like
you said right your dad never got the
opportunity maybe even when he had kids
to show him no
you know his parents were they're like a
lot of people are toxic in your family
and you don't know until you get old
enough to find
out so you know um
being that being that you know i i've
i've have three different prison numbers
this is not my first time in prison but
it's my last time
good [ __ ] so make that clear nice
nice i i've uh you know
i've gone to prison for different things
my first time in prison was for
something that i was just doing to
protect my family you know
to protect my sister who were you uh
when i first went yeah i was in my 20s
bro
so yeah and then and and the thing is
like
i was a professional skateboarder and
you had to go to [ __ ] prison as a
professional skateboarder
while i was a skateboarding professional
i had they hadn't just hadn't
discontinued my boards yet but
i had got so heavily into drugs what
drugs
crack cocaine papa oh you know dogs and
[ __ ]
no p it started with p dogs i graduated
to the
petals yeah yeah i was a rowdy roddy
piper my boy
crack ooh you must be fighting the [ __ ]
at everybody smoking crack boy i turned
you that haircut right there i should
have been wearing that clark kent
i was like smallville i was i was
crackville you know what i'm saying
i was strong when you when you smoke you
just me i just i got i got
you get straight i get really i get
really like yeah like i'm
my antennas go up and i'm thinking
you're yeah i just get
suspicious i'm suspicious of everybody
even this is too close to me holmes
you know away from me but around this
you want to steal my [ __ ] yeah
everything just everything you're like
you're even afraid to look at yourself
it's like a demon it's like a demon in a
possessed like hey that person said
something about you you know they didn't
go [ __ ] stop go stab go beat them up
cocaine cowboys man cocaine warriors
skunk that one now scott that warrior is
not that's just different no i don't
i've never done that
no that's kind of good good man that's
just disgusting bro
and one time i did do it the one time i
did but through the nose like i snorted
it
hurt like the girl was like yeah you're
gonna
and i was like what is this pink [ __ ]
like what is this pink yeah it was pink
it was like pink back in the 90s it was
pink
and i don't and i'm just looking at it
like i do white stuff i don't do pink
yeah what are you giving me yeah i
didn't like math it's gonna protect it's
gonna affect my performance
down there you know what i'm saying
she's like no it's gonna enhance it
it's going to be good you're going to be
like a rock star all night damn
girl my thing said my thing said
dude off the chris and it was just like
dead
it was dead and then there was nothing
to it and i was just like oh my goodness
not doing this drug no more
i had noodle chili bro and i've never
had noodle chili before i've never had
heard of tommy's chili i've heard of
like
chilies but not noodle chili noodle
chili is good not good bro
so now when you're trying to like be
like dirk diggler and
you know it's not good oh [ __ ] okay
so um how long do you have to go to
prison the first time
in your 20s you said no well they
sentenced me seven years
but i ended up doing i should have been
home six years six months but i ended up
doing
eight years and some change no more you
did some [ __ ] in there yeah
yeah yeah that's how it's sad man you
get put in a place that you kind of
don't have a chance unless you
stay by yourself you study you do this
you get your degrees but
jail's like a a criminal playground it's
like yo let's learn some other [ __ ] that
i know this guy's teaching me this and
this guy's gonna teach me that [ __ ]
yeah this guy's teaching me how to make
bruno
this guy's teaching me how to hoop a
knife
like hey there's some crazy i've i've
seen some
i've heard the craziest stories in there
it's like it's bad man like uh
you know prison is not the place to be
no
you know listen i know and i don't man
that's the one of the reasons why i want
to
get more involved in speaking to the
youth and
you know i want to go back to the
prisons
that i've been to and to all of them if
i could you know i've um
i i've i've been to i've been to about
six or seven of them and
you know being transferred once they're
getting transferred because you're
fighting yeah yeah yeah so it's
it's an ugly place man like you know
well yeah they transfer you because your
points either go up
and you get transferred fighting and
i would like to go back and speak to the
youth or the men's
prisons you know it would be cool to to
be an example not to show off or nothing
yeah yeah to be an example and give
these guys some hope
to let them know you know like hey if i
could do it you could do it homie
because you got to remember like if your
friend gets a sick ass job like yo you
got to
maybe i can get a sick ass job it's
motivation it's not envy it's more
motivation
you know and you know but there's too
many brocheros over there bro you know
what a
brocha is right he's like oh yeah a
brush
in english it's a brush to coat my hair
no
[ __ ] stop thinking of your hair a
brochure is a mustache homie
okay okay so when i say broshero it's
like all the brocheros you know the
the a homie yeah when they talk they're
like yosemite sam
homie the mustache goes homies
routine time homie you know like their
their mustache actually goes up like
that
you know what i'm saying i know what you
said the cholo yosemite sam something
this would pose a bench yeah
bro that was google go blood and blood
out oh my god look at wyatt earp over
there
look at wyatt earp homie what he brought
up the come on
ben stiller he's got beds if i cut mine
right now up to there it's ben stiller
yeah yeah zoolander
yeah but this takes yeah let's see now
i'm talking about the second guy
yeah okay so you know what i'm trying to
say of course yeah my uncle
is right there that's your uncle right
there yeah that's like one of my uncles
right there
so you know um those there's some dudes
that just hard-headed that
you know they love where they're at yeah
they love where they're at they love
whether
you know they they i'm never going home
that's all right i don't
oh you know it's sad i like they they
just don't see themselves
they don't even want to try they got too
much time or whatever and they just lose
hope you know yeah
i mean and they and they figure like
well now they're not going to consider
me but they
are you know the thing is they are man
and
it's just a it's a personal thing yeah
man you live there you i mean
that you i mean i said you didn't know
that before but when you went in there
now you're learning like oh you have 30
years [ __ ] you're not going to see your
kids gross she's going to be married by
the time you get a [ __ ] okay well you
got a lot
it's a whole different perspective when
you think like i'm with somebody that's
never getting go home i get to go home
soon
it's humbling it's yeah it makes you
think like i'm wasting my time i'm
squandering my time like this full did
i can't do that it's humbling man like
it makes you think
like you know it it made me
like i i'm like man here i am
you know i got a good thing out here i
have a good thing
before i got locked up i was doing the
trollos tribe videos which were
pretty popular at the time i seen it and
they were they they
were doing good and i was we were all
signed by
me too and comcast comcast is huge
yeah they had us on a big platform
taking us all around the united states
doing all kinds of shows
besides that i was getting a lot of work
acting and well you were doing acting
before you went to jealous last time oh
okay i was sick
so i know we circled back i've done a
bunch of like television and
a few films and stuff you know like oh
no [ __ ] yeah so like
uh uh america's most wanted the
southland
dexter sons of anarchy um
thousand ways to die yeah pop goes to
cholo
i was yeah i popped the cholo you know
oh
we blew them up i was wondering like yo
how do they find the people do the
reenactments man that's just tight
yeah nice that's how you started started
all this yeah see that's such a cool
direction though when you see yourself
like oh [ __ ]
that's me look where i'm at it's it's
motivating for yourself and it's kind of
like a pattern
and when you're sitting in prison let me
tell you when you're sitting in jail and
you're like
like and you look and you're thinking
man that's me and then
nowadays they have phones in prison so
they pop it up and be like
you know damn and it's it's like a kick
in the head
you want to use where you were man look
at you now like you're
you know think about all the times that
if i had just
been like this now i would have never
even gotten i would have been like so
much more progress so fast yeah but
you know if you think about that it's
like okay i would have but
god had a plan for me to see all that to
go through all that because i know now
what i got right now i had to go through
what i went through
because because what i went through has
changed me and it was meant for me to go
through that [ __ ] and like i know that
it had to be
so if i never went through it i would
never be the person i am today
so i'm so grateful for all the stuff
that i've been through and
survived and and by and and just
had to witness to be here so now that i
could help others
if i hadn't done that i wouldn't
appreciate i wouldn't be here and i
wouldn't be appreciating the things and
the family and the friends and the
people that are around me right now
today and all the
opportunities that i got i was taking
all that for granted before
because i had the spotlight before i had
the spotlight and spotlight
i just took it for granted and now that
i have a platform and i'm gonna build
off of it
and i'm gonna build my own brand sure
and my name
and i'm gonna and i'm gonna collaborate
with others now
it's now's the time that i should be out
here doing this because
i had to go through that i had to see
pelican bay i had to see san quentin
and all those other level four prisons i
had to go through the fights
and and the time the extra time that i
got the shoe terms
the stabbies all that the drugs on the
streets and and and the
failed relationships and like rebuilding
it with my kids and
i had to go through all that man and i
had to fall
and i i've always i always fall bro
but you know one thing about me i get up
and i dust myself off
and i just get get ready to go again and
that's how i am in life period
yes because even back then um when you
were younger going to jail get in
trouble and you said you had the
spotlight
you threw it away knowing you're gonna
throw it away knowing it but
i think with age two comes with age no
it comes it comes with wisdom
it comes with wisdom and experience age
might have a
a factor in it but i know some younger
guys that
are younger and the experience they went
through
it just changed them so people are
different man that's
everybody just it's it's it's your it's
timing and it's
it's like now is the time and it's not
my time it's
it's it's uh it's god's time for
whatever he wants
and whatever he wants me to do you know
if he wants
i'm not doing it no more every morning i
wake up and i and i give it to the man
upstairs you know
i always give it to the man upstairs
first because without that
i could i can't do by myself because the
drug
itself is too strong like the thoughts
and the addiction i've already relapsed
like so many times in the past
so now i know i've never done this
before in the past
to like to to to actually pray and to
work on myself yeah so now i'm doing it
differently
good and now it's it's i feel stronger
and i could pass by those old
neighborhoods where
did not pick up and not and no no no
good [ __ ] though that's
it's like looking at uh your old life
going yeah the effort is dead now look
at me now
hey i might my stomach might turn and i
might get that nervous ghaka when i pass
through that neighborhood because i used
to smoke crack on that block
and and i still get that nervous cocker
when i go to auditions i even had the
nervous doctor coming in here
you know what i'm saying because
somebody
called me and or text me on the phone
and said hey
you're almost there cause i'll be there
right now i'm taking a [ __ ] this will
take so he
put the visual in my head and now i can
see is some
[ __ ] big burly ass hairy man taking a
[ __ ]
and now i need to take a [ __ ] and that
that that's
like resurrected my my kaka
to come and and my my nervous kaka just
started and then like right when i got
in here
and then we started talking chopping it
up and right now like you know it's gone
but i'm not trying to wake it up you
know what i'm saying
because because that's and but someone
i already took i took my daily kaka you
know what i'm saying but the homie
brought it up back up and he just like
it got got boiling in there you know
saying he started to they start mixing
it i used to get that feeling when i was
uh
selling sacks that people haven't met
yet ah i hated that [ __ ] maybe it had
something to do with the gummy bears and
water and
the naked juice i had for breakfast
probably i had gummy bears
gummy bears and naked juice yeah
combination yeah that's a bad combo
maybe it's that too yeah it probably is
dude
naked juice runs right through you
though that's just bomb though try that
soldier s-u-j-o-i
i think bomb is [ __ ] that green juice
it's not so sugary and [ __ ]
i [ __ ] with that i don't know merc said
merced is like i met a lot of people
from merced
for real yeah i was in prison yeah a lot
of people in prison
merced california there's a lot there's
like a lot of uh
northerners there's even homies from
there you know i meant different both
sides
both sides of the only two or three
times i ever saw fools with blue and
shaved heads
put it that way like in my whole life
and they were scary as [ __ ] that's all i
remember like if those fools come to
merced
something's going the [ __ ] down just
some shit's going down because they
don't just walk around merced
everybody's got red hair they're there
to do something to do there to do
something it's just scary i mean i know
those people
do your thing i'm selling weed like
that's why i said i avoided this whole
life
i grew up on second street all gangs
that's that's what it is
he grew up on second street that's for
number two
cocka [ __ ] this was like a comedian just
roasting the [ __ ] out of cocka
second street gangs
second street number two
no disrespect no i'm gonna have some
food from second street come run up on
me now
look it was a joke homie yeah it's just
it was a joke
and when i go to merced it's all good i
mean i'm just joking second street homie
hey you guys are cool man hey nah
there's not it's not like that as much
as i
don't play that everybody's just i don't
play [ __ ] i know i know but people are
sensitive no you can't say
you can't say certain things you can't
say a lot of things i mean you can't
like i even feel bad for saying smear
the earlier
you know maybe i already said it though
so i'm just talking about how am i
censoring myself now yeah
but yeah but either way just you know
hey man i'm not worried about people
sensitive homie
people are so like touchy when it comes
to like i think the world needs to shape
up man
and just stop and get over it like i
like
comedians like eddie murphy and richard
pryor
delirious are all my favorites george
carlin like dudes like that i could just
say
wrong but you just raised off the three
probably best comedians of all time
almost
and like those are my favorite because
they're [ __ ] raunchy and dirty and
then they
laugh they say what they feel and they
say what's real
yeah that's before the cancel [ __ ] came
that's before although like hey here's
your career [ __ ] you yeah
all that hashtag [ __ ] yeah yeah but like
bill burr trying to get canceled just
don't care and it doesn't happen that
[ __ ] ain't canceled
there's certain there's just certain
ways you hold yourself and hey i want to
be a comedian too you can be a comedian
you can too
for well you you're [ __ ] you're funny
he's a [ __ ] comedian already about to
read your weather
that's how i see it yeah about to read
the [ __ ] weather and sell you some
drugs yeah
you look like a younger like the 12 year
old version of fluffy
like why do i get that so much because
because
he grew into you and glacier you grew
into him i mean yeah he's like
yeah he's the the dude with the the dude
he has hair like that but he's a little
bit larger yeah he's a big let's not say
the word that we get banned from like i
don't want to say i don't want a fat
shame nobody i'm fat that feels fast
yeah but he's
he's a little fluffier he likes to be
cough he's fat homie i'm fat too
if you can't take that joke hey man you
need to you need to shape the [ __ ] up
yeah see if you're cool with goatee and
we're a little beret and a
hawaiian shirt no he'll know see he'll
be like episode 100
we got to do that [ __ ] pull-up
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's right anything man have him on
the show
be like before and after damn before and
after
this one's got no [ __ ] confidence in
me and [ __ ]
hell no [ __ ] out of here now episode 100
i'll be in shape again
[ __ ] that right you're all right i
already made the promise you know what i
say you're okay
as long as you can look down and see
your ding ding you're good
cause if you can't look down and see
your ding dong homie you're doing bad
i think it's if you're on the edge of a
cliff and you're about to fall can you
pull yourself up then you're not in
[ __ ] shape
that's not i think like i'll be on the
edge of a cliff one day i need to be
able to pull ups
i bet you you're gonna be using your
ding ding before you hit a [ __ ] cliff
like if you get that you know you won't
be standing on no cliff no time soon but
you
might have an opportunity to be like
look down and
and maybe make an impression with your
ding-dong you know what i'm saying
like a [ __ ] guess i mean if your wang
is like underneath everything and you
just gotta you gotta lift up too
yo sorry sorry fluffy that we started
talking about all this [ __ ]
i mean dude you know they can't see your
dick you're doing bad
i don't disagree with you i mean maybe
you got a big dick i don't know i'll
disagree with you though
i said we're having a pissing contest
here hey man i don't know about these
games i don't know what scamming
game you're talking about man i mean
there's two two two people
okay look i know you said this you never
heard of it before
never heard anybody say it though like
that in my life she's from merced
okay so look scamming back in the day
was like hey fool you want to scam me
and you tell lahaina that you go like
hey girl
hey i kind of like you you want to scam
and she says either you're stupid
and she has braces you're stupid she's
like you're stupid but okay
yeah let's do it after school nah let's
do it in lunch fool
[ __ ] it let's do it right now you got
bad breath
and then she's like nah why fool do you
and you make her feel all conscious you
make her feel self-conscious right so
you make her
and then you bring her back up by like
hey look i don't mind spit breath come
on
and then you you just scam on her yeah
you still never heard that
i never heard you kiss her and when you
start you don't go like this
you start out you starve you go and then
just like you both just connect like
there's your tongues here's your mouth
and you just you don't even kiss like
it's not a
it's just like
it's ugly you remember when we brought
this [ __ ] thing up what the
[ __ ] was that yo scammings when you kiss
me till you're telling this
you're a bad brand and you kind of make
that noise be a [ __ ] comedian
you're supposed to make that noise
you're supposed to make that noise when
you scam
nah hell no i was a uh uh
[ __ ] that and then and then and then you
go down and then give the hickey fool
this was trying to teach me and [ __ ] yo
class about star house you don't do the
hickey
you never got a hickey he's from mercy
hey papa we're giving him a hickey after
the show
yo what the [ __ ] happened no i'm playing
i'm playing oh god we're not [ __ ] nah
we don't [ __ ] run like that no more
hey yo you're [ __ ] set of your comedy
it's just like y'all i'm gonna make fun
of all six of you in the [ __ ] front
row do something
[Laughter]
yo you have sold out show everything
about the front row
whoever sits in the front rows getting
done getting it and if the light can see
you i'm going after you oh [ __ ] that
[ __ ]
sit there yeah you have to take it i
want you to sit there
with me yeah i'll just sit there and
make fun of your back
that's feed me um and then i'll have to
stab you on stage
nah we'll go arm wrestle for it
i'll arm wrestle and play kickball hey
hey you got a nice show homie but we
need some ac up in here
it's hot on me or something hey
it's not it's uh the sound it [ __ ] the
sound up we just found these uh
silent fans that i'm about to get
because i asked last pockets it was the
hottest [ __ ] yeah
i mean make me want to take my [ __ ]
shirt off homie and just outdo you right
now with the muscle shirt though
that's all good bro so good
an indoor living gym homie for 24 7.
they teach you fighting
working out and regulars and i was out
here learning how to edit
yeah learning how to edit and drive i
did a four and a half
year gym [ __ ] three four year
membership this membership dog that like
that kind of the ultimate gym warrior
yeah but as soon as you're done working
out you could test out your fighting
skills
right over there test it out on that fat
boy with the haircut damn this was crazy
watch in six months man i'm gonna be all
buffer shield you're waiting to see in
six
months i'll show you
yeah keep eating your wheaties fat boy
thank you
yo this was crazy as [ __ ] not for real
though
but not for real though yeah good six
months if you've got to stay on it
though
you ain't gonna stay on it it's hard bro
yeah but you gotta stay on it though
[ __ ] four jobs
you have four jobs well two of them
consist of
feels crazy as hell over here eating and
driving one of them's driving one of
them's eating the other one's sleeping
the other one's just [ __ ] watching tv
dude going like this
oh you got me all [ __ ] up that's not
me no no you don't do that i own all
these businesses
that'll help you work out too homie
that's a good workout okay you'll be all
big for one arm no i got [ __ ] to do oh
you got [ __ ]
unless you want to pay for this
warehouse yeah yeah you gotta you know
yes you want to pay for everything
[ __ ] that [ __ ] no i'm busy [ __ ] that i
was literally just talking about man i
hired trainer to get my [ __ ] ass up
and do this
you know what i like this spot it's dope
yeah no stuff i [ __ ] with it and i heard
you got a big audience so
yeah i hope i reach out to some people
and
you know if you find me funny
offensive offensive and if you got hair
like mine you want to make fun of him
yeah
that's all right if you don't look i
can't grow my hair no more too many head
spins in the 80s
i lost my [ __ ] but i always say yeah
how'd you lose your damn you lost your
hair yeah too many head spins and
windmills in the 80s
rip that [ __ ] out windmills [ __ ] hitting
pookies
hey homie no pookie homie you went like
this yeah but that's that's that's
that's a
that's skante warrior of [ __ ] yeah i
don't really see people hit crack pipes
where i'm from ever
because it's always the ball crack is
whack they don't do it no more they all
graduated to
meth methamphetamine yeah yeah i see
crack bites in downtown but that's it
i don't i first time i ever saw one i
always see pookies i don't see crab
pipes
nobody carries a shore boy no more dawg
i see that [ __ ] all the time
yeah short boy all the time what a
pusher oh yeah
the uh the uh but they won't know how
clean but i bet they have a pusher like
mine my pusher had
resin and blood on it that had dna and
resin crack residue with dna that's how
i got busted
what yeah that's how you get in trouble
with this last time yeah not this last
time fool
but the first time when i was i i i
stopped smoking
i don't do that no more well you're
laughing at me you sparked a joint yeah
there's a reason why i haven't sparked a
joint
no i didn't want to i don't know but i
had crack residue and dna and it wasn't
from that guy
that i that i got busted for it was from
the dna they didn't even know it was
from a different
dna yeah i had like two different types
of dna
dog oh you stabbed somebody with this
thing and then hit you different
different stab ations nah that's what
crack does
yeah that's bad did i just say different
stabbations yeah that's
what's the word huh it wasn't well
stabbations is funny
yeah now um yeah no thanks different
stabulators is way harder i like that
way harder stability
this was over here just making fun of
the way i talk and [ __ ]
it's fine with me i don't give a [ __ ]
i'm making fun of myself
right i guess yeah
right
oh [ __ ] chairs yeah [ __ ] it um
they're going to talk [ __ ] anyway i mean
they're always going to comment and say
their little
you know they're going to give me but
when they see you they don't say nothing
on me that's the true statement when
they see you they don't say no
they're gonna talk on the internet and
that's fine because haters
make me famous there it is we don't get
much bad
[ __ ] on our stuff man like 99 positive
that's good yeah
pretty much that's good you get a few a
few here and there but but uh but
i i don't i don't even trip on that no
more you know because i don't comment on
the internet
yeah i don't take it personal or nothing
but unless you get in my face
that's different though if somebody says
something slightly
root to you in person's like yo you're
brave here we go here we go
yeah i don't know man internet got so
many stories about people bro
people come at me with all kinds of
crazy stuff like oh man
you're this guy who you know used to do
this and do that and
and like uh yeah yeah whatever like
there's bad stuff about me there's good
stuff and then like
there's his there his story her story
and then there's the truth you know
there's always two sides in there
whatever man i go with the flow homie
yeah that's all good
you want me to be that guy i'll be that
guy some people say i'm a vegan
i am vegan how is it that vegans are
like overweight homeopathies
skinny it used to be fatter full you
used to be fatter yeah
and now i'm not as fat fatter than that
yeah full damn fool
yeah serious it's not not cereal man i
said
i'm just kidding like serial
pedro i don't know what the [ __ ] that
just happened
but yeah no but really no but you were
okay so you lost some weight
and now you're no you look good more of
it's more of a
[Music]
there's skinny people that are going to
have a heart attack tomorrow it don't
matter if you're skinny or fat
are you unhealthy inside right that's
what most people like like
like you're used to be fat like you know
people tell people call me fat mole
i don't give a [ __ ] call me broke they
don't get pissed the [ __ ] off right
like that's different right like call me
if i don't give a [ __ ] like
nothing nothing yeah you're not even fat
bro you're like i'm just
bigger and i'm trying to keep me you're
chunky and that's good
like chunky's good i like chunky soup i
like chunky everything i like meat that
chunky i like
chunky chunky now you guys it's okay
yeah it's okay to be chunky it's good
it's cool food like me
i've never i've never been that way and
i
i i'm just because i've always been
active skating and yeah
well dude i was acting my whole life i
was still a fat kid even when i was
playing four sports i think it's jeans
homies my whole family is this [ __ ]
big yeah they're yeah so when you come
from that yeah so hey
yeah they're all you're just healthy
fool you can never like not use the day
you go skinny it's going to be
like damn yeah there it goes we get a
movie deal he's on crack
yeah for real though yeah i swear man i
was telling martin you can't be fat and
be famous like that don't work that way
like it'll be weird it's kind of like
it's like um fat albert going skinny
he's a regular dude
it's not funny no more it's like if
chris farley was scared he'd be like
jonah hill jonah hill he's directing now
though that should hold different things
okay so he's directly different path now
you seen that movie in the mid 90s that
he did
right it was good hey trip out on this
it's good speaking of the mid 90s
movie i seen it at home right i
got out i seen it like when i first got
my apartment and i'm watching it
and i'm like this fool jonah hill
did a movie on called mid 90s
about skateboarding nikhil
that kid with the dreads left that's
kareem campbell's
nephew get the [ __ ] out of here cream
campbell me and him we we all skated on
the same team menace we started menace
and city stars that's his nephew
and we all we all came up together
kareem all of us and we did
videos called uh 20 shot sequence we
started a
company called menace we did city stars
while nikail was on that movie right
there
but we that you know so we all [ __ ]
we all kind of like contributed to that
movie and i didn't get no failure from
it
oh you i'm not done for no money i
didn't get no money
he he pretty much put the crew that we
started
doc there's a doc in that film
he put dlc doped out children doped out
creations
that's a crew that got started by my
homie gyro
gideon my homie my homie juan was a
i don't want to say his tagging name
because he's still active and
um dlc is still
out there and um and we're all still so
they use
the actual name yeah it's like the the
hashtag we use is defending our culture
and i remember seeing that film and
he actually put like the real [ __ ]
tagging dlc
and menace and he used our menace logo
the the city the the [ __ ] that we was
rocking that we
and i don't know if maybe kareem gave
them the thumbs up or whoever did but
i i mean i i like it i i think it's cool
that he gave us the
the uh the props and the shout out
because a little tiny chat it's kind of
like
it's kind of like a like a like a a you
know
paying homage to us and you're forever
stamped in culture right
you got to think of it like that it's
like and i do never go away i don't ever
i don't think like hey man why did you
do it no i
i was like [ __ ] yeah i was like happy
like damn they actually acknowledged
our era mm-hmm see i think when you're
younger skating this [ __ ] like
yeah you're skating you didn't think in
20 years it's gonna be ingrained in a
[ __ ]
big movie you know chico brennes
rick howard and a few other
skateboarders i remembered in there like
daniel castillo and i i maybe um
damn i don't know who else uh maybe mike
carroll i'm not sure but
i i've seen a few eric costa
maybe but i've seen a few guys in that
movie at the end they played like other
they played like they played the cops in
it they played different characters in
there and and little
they came out as like little um
background or whatever
chad musca was in that movie so maybe
really i didn't see him chad musk
was in that film didn't see that with
that dude from the far side
um uh um from dale the funky homophobia
was the uh he was the homeless dude he
was a homeless guy at the courthouse
hieroglyphics hieroglyphics yeah
hieroglyphics i'm sure i saw myself so
that's [ __ ] dell right there
so chad chad muska was in it and [ __ ]
i was like maybe he
or they all like said you know and i
thank them for that because you know
what it's true and it's right like
um i don't like toot my own horn here
like you know
pat myself on the back or not but we did
we did
make a dent in the skateboard game in
the 90s
we did make a impact and along with
other companies like
girl chocolate world industries you know
plan b we all together
there was another company like with like
uh the shoe companies and
all the dvs and dc and globe and
etnies and all of them paid like you
know even duff
like we all had uh uh we paid our
part to it and dude we made it [ __ ]
huge man we did it we there was a
company called 101
and it was sick it was like i thought it
was one of the best companies out there
and ours wasn't
but i loved 101 because it had like all
six skaters it had like nadas kappas
gabe rodriguez rest in peace gino
ayannucci
and uh you know jason dale was in it i
think after
and um we had like uh there was a big
a lot of us man and we all hung out and
skated together
we went on tour so
yeah we were we were we did our thing
but we weren't the best skateboarders
but they liked us because of our
personalities and the way we carried
ourselves and where we come from
i think more or less because those dudes
were skating at like a stupid level
[ __ ]
we were skating good i think we were me
personally i think i was like skating
okay but
i don't think i i was skating at that
crazy level like i could have pushed
myself
more what held me back was um
environment too where you're from and
just getting high
so much which i mean mentally just weeds
yeah just like getting yeah the weed and
partying you're partying partying
when you're young and you're [ __ ]
killing it you're skating out of your
neighborhood you're the only one that's
like no that full
skate's pro it's different when you come
from a neighborhood like that i yeah
i [ __ ] i feel you my family they
never seen nothing
[ __ ] like this before with my family i
came home with a mat with a magazine
of with me in it and
i showed them and pretty pretty soon
like i was like wow you're in a magazine
and then like the videos came out like
the little commercial 411 videos
i don't know if you remember the four
one i was in like a bunch of them and
you know different magazines like big
brother and all these things i started
getting interviews and
like i sk before all this i skated for z
i was a z boy
i don't know if you know about z z
products z dot
dogtown z boy i've heard i've heard of
that before my homies uh okay so that's
the old that was like one of the first
first eight that's like 70 [ __ ] okay so
i got on in the 80s
and you know that was like old right
there did your parents embrace that [ __ ]
were they hyped
they were like you're a skater homie
what are you
turning into a white boy same here
that's what i got
like and then they then they kind of
like made fun of me my uncle's a little
bit like everybody like my dad was like
what are you gonna do on a skateboard
how are you gonna how do you expect to
make money but he had no idea
pro [ __ ] professional skater that's a
real job
he used to get on me before i turn pro
he's get on me about it like
how are you gonna how are you gonna what
are you gonna do how are you gonna make
money on a skateboard
and that's crazy mentality this yeah
your dad's over here selling drugs
he's like skating that's stupid like
so it's it's environment it's all that
that picture right there you just put up
that's there was a fight that broke out
right there i don't know if you see my
uncle rest in peace shark on the end
mad dogging the left yeah yeah see him
on the right he's mad dogging everybody
on the on the left
because oh [ __ ] we caught the tension in
the picture that's
yeah bro you don't need to stare there's
a lot of people that don't really
trip on that but there's a fight that
broke out
right after that and okay so
see the dude behind him now go look good
you see the guy behind
the guy mad dogging okay that's my uncle
shark rest in peace he died
no no other one him no that's my brother
right there my brother got busted at 14
right after that he got busted for a
murder
and didn't come home until a few months
ago so
he did he sent this in 22 years so tripp
that that one right there that that guy
now look at the guy behind him see the
guy behind him yeah there's a bald head
behind him
oh [ __ ] you could barely see it look at
all right between the two look in
between my brother and my uncle
i just said so those fools jumped on
these fools over here with that with the
jersey and the 18 jerseys
taking the same picture jumping each
other right after that picture was taken
them all the food just started getting
into it like and the doo doo doo doo
actually took the picture
he does a lot of [ __ ] for jackass right
now his name is rick
kosic okay oh big white dude big white
dude you know where
the classes yeah yeah and um rick kosick
was like
he practically peed his pants got
nervous
said dude are we gonna be like here are
we all right man like i was like dude we
cool man they just you know that they
ain't gonna
escalate to that but i'm gonna hurry up
and get i'm gonna escort you get back to
my car yeah he he was freaking out and i
hate to do that to my friends because
they don't live this world they're not
they
don't live this life and it's different
so that's my son
with the flannel sitting on my
skateboard and then the
the boy next to him is my nephew
and my godson rest in peace anthony
right here
and that's he died also
right a little bit before my uncle
uh right after my was i believe they
both died around the same time
um anthony passed away
at the age of 23 oh [ __ ] from
heart failure drinking certain drinks i
don't know what it was his his heart
just gave up
yeah with certain certain ups and then
the it brings you down yeah my uncle
passed away from a drug overdose and um
and and so my brother right there
my uncle fatso the one next to the one
mad doggy my uncle fatso the one
in between the hat he
he he got shot he he was shot by
you know and and he survived he almost
died but my other uncle that was with
him
passed away from that that same incident
and my brother
[ __ ] my brother right there he got
busted for a murder a little bit after
this film
at the age of 14 and barely came home
[Music]
uh did did uh 22 years
and he came home um last year like in
august or september you're the same
mentality as you when you got out yeah
no i mean like now the one you oh no
he's good now now now he's
he's on a straight and narrow yes i'm
hoping you're like right there oh no
he's good
he's good and he's got a bunch of
degrees and like he studied a lot
because i went to college too homie i
went to college and
he's got like degrees so i just got some
credits and units in college for
and college of the redwoods in pelican
bay and um
so that kind of narrowed down my time
and everything everything about play
played in you know how productive you
are the more they look the more
productive you are
yes the more you stay productive and you
stay doing good because too much time on
your hands is like
it's the worst thing in the world yeah
and then you're bored and you're
surrounded by negativity
and then you just want to either like
get loaded or you want to hurt somebody
and you're just like you know
people love it's like entertainment for
someone to get stabbed on the yard
it's like oh man i can't wait to see
this
snake it's a negative energy man i'm
gonna do a good job out there you know
and then you want to go out there and
represent for your homies too you want
to go out there and make yourself shine
because everybody's going to talk about
it you know ah that fool didn't do a
good holiday man that full [ __ ] whack
he didn't even get him
you want to be the one that like you
they say damn did you see that fool go
out there
he did his thing he stood on here it's a
crazy mentality though man to have
yeah it's a it's a bad one to have i
feel like no if you're in that
environment
it's like points it's like video game
points i believe it's if you're
now if you're in that world stupid
points like ding ding ding ding ding
you're going all the way to the top
now if you can somehow manage to cross
into this from negative to positive and
put a spin on it
and use that same mentality you're
unstoppable which i want
that's the [ __ ] that i'm on right now
i'm doing
exactly what i was doing in there i'm
putting that same energy and that same
mentality
into the the positive spin that i'm
on right now and to doing the outreach
and the the acting and the the giving
back
and and and the the community um
outreach that i'm doing with people as
far as
you know uh being engaging in and doing
speaking
engagements at schools whether it be for
kids or skate parks or whatever it is
even on this
platform of yours now you know like
that's what i want to do and
that's why i take advantage when when
people ask me
if i want to do their podcast because
there's only a selective feel that i
want to do i don't want to do
all of every single podcast and it's
like the flame
turns into a little spark can make
yourself too accessible
i don't want to do that but i do want to
do it on ones that
have a big platform and a lot and
a big reach that you know that where
people are actually a lot of people are
seeing it
so you know the
the the story is never going to change
it's just the way it's delivered
might change but the story remains the
same it's just a delivery
and everyone's got a story everyone does
you know so
you know be yeah i always keep in mind
like i'm not the only one
with the story here everyone's got their
story and everyone has their reasons for
you know doing this and doing that and
like you may seem like you know
and me i i come in with jokes homie i i
i i say everything
like i know that everyone whether it be
weight problem
gangs whether you're you you know
whatever it be it be
um whatever impediment you have or
you know disability whatever it is i
look at it like
god has you like that for a reason and
and it's to
make you a better person to come out of
it because we're all
we all got our flaws bro you know every
all of us got flaws and
and and now i think it's a beautiful
thing our imperfections
are are beautifully accepted you know
and
and uh if we were all perfect ken dolls
man it would be weird
you know or yeah boring and plus a ken
doll has no bulge down there it's all
smooth
you know what i'm saying also we'd have
no dicks
yeah we'd be smooth down there he said
it no dicks but we did
i don't i don't want to be a kin doll i
want to have a bulge you know what i'm
saying
yo bro you gotta start you gotta tighten
these and start
doing some jokes bro cause that's just
and you gotta remember it's a
contrast it's all contrast like someone
looks at you like
you're probably not gonna be funny like
no actually it's [ __ ] funny it's a
contrast you look at me like oh he's
probably square right
i sold all your [ __ ] parents drugs
for yeah [ __ ] you
it is but you didn't never don't judge
the book yeah it's always
there's a reason there's a reason
everybody looks the way they do it it's
it's environment too man like you said
like you said it's all environment um
i like the way you put that that was
great thank you for that that was cool
you know you know man
i like i like messing around and joking
and stuff but there's a time to be
serious too homie you know
and and right now i'm about to be a
serious put your location
no i'm not going to see but i don't know
how to do that you know so hopefully he
puts me in one of those he's got some
some he puts me in a video and i'd be
like come on like oh yeah
oh yeah
no no you know i just come out singing
maybe like a whole different person with
that [ __ ] up yeah yeah and i go back to
this
all i see when i see that face go i'ma
keep walking the store i don't know what
the [ __ ] you're talking about hell no
hey homie go oh no i'm good look at me
when i'm asking you for money homie
right look at me when i'm asking you
do you have any change homes look at me
when i'm asking you for change homie
though
[Applause]
help me out explain that [ __ ] tekato is
a cholo or an old school veteran or
whatever anybody
anybody but usually they this is the
term that
slams dope damn decatur
they don't get too old though yeah this
one said tech smacks
this [ __ ] you said something oh
yes
it's [ __ ] this [ __ ] looks like a.d
kingston i know [ __ ] that
i don't even know who it is either but i
heard he's [ __ ] got a music
label i have no idea he plays the guitar
for selena her brother holmes
and man that's a good movie all right
that's not [ __ ] the movie
that's a good movie leave the movie
alone bro i got selena tatted on my
chest
i got it in texas in texas in tex-mex
no i don't i don't speak spanish either
you don't speak spanish no my whole
family is
i don't really speak spanish either i
just know like slang
prison and cuss words and how to buy
drugs yeah i'll say so you know all the
basics
yeah like i know someone wants to beat
me up i want to jump me i can hear it
i'm like
you know you understand that i heard
something [ __ ] at the end that's all i
heard
something something something i know
when these folks are talking [ __ ] about
me
that's all i know what's up everybody
today's episode is brought to you by
manscaped
for everyone out there that follows our
other social medias and everything you
guys know we have been on a trial run
sponsorship of manscape not because we
[ __ ] suck but just because we're
brand new so they can't just give us a
contract
hey you guys are 10 episodes in we trust
you so what we did guys did a trial run
period and marty and i knocked it out
the [ __ ] park
but in reality you guys did thank you
guys for using the code i had so many
dm's
you guys using the code and getting the
shipping and the discount code so thank
you guys for helping us out
you made us look [ __ ] awesome so
thank you and thank you to manscaped
since it's a trial run guys the code
yola is no longer active so this is what
you're going to want to do
it's manscape.com yola that's how you
get our discount you'll see it it says
as heard on dope's usual podcast it says
it right there it's a landing page
the link is in the description every
single video the link is in the
description guys
it's on our instagram it's on our
website it's on our twitter but make
sure you click the link in the
description
of this video and that's how you go
directly get your 20 off you get free
shipping so in the end guys thank you
so much thank you for making it possible
we are in episode 13 14-ish right now
and
it's just working well so thank you guys
for being active thank you for
supporting on today's product guys today
we are the
one of the first podcasts we were one of
the first people to get this new product
for manscape i'm hyped as [ __ ] to say
that
right here guys this is the lawnmower
point lawnmower faux pas
full i kinda can't talk my [ __ ]
invisalign just
made me sound like a little kid 4.0
i sound like one of those kids that
can't pronounce the odds
[ __ ] marty lawn mower 4.0
you know what uh commercials where it
says paid actor not a paid actor let's
just say right here
not a paid actor but we are paid for the
ad you could say
but this is a genuine review this
[ __ ] works
i was really scared guys i even closed
my eyes i didn't went
oh my god my dick didn't get cut off
because i'm [ __ ] scared of using
blades next to my dick
but i used it and it didn't hurt it
didn't cut me i was expecting to see
blood
and nothing happen i'm very excited to
tell you guys
these actually work all right so for me
to you if you've ever been shaving and
you cut your [ __ ] balls open i've
done it once when i was in high school
it scared the [ __ ] out of me so guys if
that's ever happened to you
don't do it again this thing has a
[ __ ] light on it a wireless charger
it is the iphone for your dick
yeah they but they never taught you now
that's their [ __ ] fault that's their
phone that's their fault and that was
not your
it's not your fault that you should have
picked up in school or picked up a book
or maybe raised your hand and said
can i pick it the spanish i want to
learn i'm in america i don't speak
spanish in class
why could you why don't you want to
everyone's mexican around i bet you that
white boy even knows spanish homie
what else he orders
he orders tacos and and
i can't chew but yo can i get it roll
those like
because he has a latina girlfriend and
he goes she told him you better learn to
roll your arms [ __ ] you ain't
hitting this
damn you ain't gonna get in the whole
life you ain't
oh you got a white girl he's married
[Laughter]
but i did it so what it's all good um
but yeah no i wanted to uh break that
before we started talking about
random [ __ ] again the way you broke down
the positivity on coming out and i think
a lot of people don't
get to see that you know what i'm saying
they don't get to see that from a person
that is an actual person not just some
dude in a suit you know i used to be in
jail
it's more of like an actual purse like
novel i'm an actual human
i'm out look what i'm doing you're
saying you put all your energy into
positivity is
unstoppable you know what i'm saying
like it's
it's r there's nothing that can stop you
unless you stop
yeah i mean i'm my own worst enemy bro
everybody is man i've created some good
stuff and then just
knocked it all down by my ways of
thinking and old habits to start
creeping back up because when you get
money
when you get money and you start getting
those triggers passing by those same
streets and then like
don't think it i still get those i still
get those crazy thoughts
i still get those crazy thoughts like
damn but i don't act on it
that's the number one thing i'd be like
damn
i said all the time you think i want to
go [ __ ] rail across this table right
[ __ ] now of course i do
coke is fun but that's just bad for you
yeah it's gonna lead to me no more money
that's why i don't do it no more yeah
and i don't wanna die yeah i don't wanna
die i got [ __ ] to do tomorrow
i don't know what to do i don't wanna my
jaw's hurt from going like this
you know what i'm saying i'm [ __ ]
over here trying to bite my own ear off
all day long and like and how's that
going to look the camera don't lie
oh camera don't [ __ ] lie it even adds
10 pounds to you i heard
you're gonna look as big as i do right
watch when you get on this we're gonna
add some fat to this guy when we [ __ ]
edit this video please
all right you want to [ __ ] make me
you want to make it out of the studio
homie make me skinnier and make him feel
better
april goodbye homie because you're not
going to leave in this [ __ ] studio
text her right now i see you she's gonna
[ __ ] break through this wall
that's all i know april
he's not going home if he does that he's
going in my trunk
i'll do it then i'll do it it's fair all
right
mark kent don't fit in my trunk so he's
going to all fit i'll [ __ ] fit
i promise you he's like oh i'll fit in
my in your truck he wants to get in my
truck huh
i've trunked many occasions to parties
before bro [ __ ] that [ __ ]
yes you know pot in the trunk to get
somewhere dude i've
been in the trunk plenty of times but
i'm voluntarily
have you ever been inside a a a dryer
machine like a washing machine you know
the dryer you ever
spin around in the driver never spawn i
never let them close never got inside
and
spin around they closed the door on you
no hell no i just kept my foot out
[ __ ] that shelf she's trapping me that's
cheating homie you gotta get in
no hell no no thank you you gotta get in
homie
you're wet you gotta get in the dryer
you gotta get in full
hey you didn't do it right hey do it
again
nine yo not even fool
you sound like oh gee and og's [ __ ]
garage right now and all his cousins hey
full dick yeah [ __ ] it shut up full day
even dick
my homie that's exactly what his whole
house sounds like it's amazing
um but uh let's wrap this up i want to
get you out of here yeah thank you for
coming thank you for chilling
thank you uh real quick before we leave
where can everybody find you at like
twitter
instagram youtube because i know you i
saw your barracks thing was sick as [ __ ]
and you still skate right now i just
still skate you're still skating i just
saw it the other day that [ __ ] was tight
as [ __ ]
it was [ __ ] oh you're still on it
it's not like you get you forgot
this i saw you at the skatepark hitting
[ __ ] yeah little jumps and [ __ ] she
was sick bro
omar no i used to skate my whole life
and i'm just we should go over it
i'm down as [ __ ] someone teach me how to
[ __ ] hit
the damn half quarter pipes my whole
life i cannot drop in
it scares me to death bro what about you
you skateboard
[ __ ] no why are you just right he's
basketball you're just dressed like one
huh
yeah that's what he's already mentioning
about the wii uh-huh
because he has places we'll go look man
we'll go to
we'll go you know we'll go we'll go push
around i'm down
i mean we could go to the barracks we
could go anywhere we could go around
venice anytime
but if you want to catch me on
any of these platforms on instagram you
catch me at fabian alomar official
on tick tock um fabian at fabian
underscore alamar
okay do you have twitter no twitter yeah
it's uh
i think it's i'll find it fabian link it
but i just suggest you start i don't
know i know you don't i didn't need it
until two years ago
best thing i ever did really it you
could do whatever you want you can't get
you can't get censored you can say
whatever you want you show whatever you
want yeah
100 uncensored and you can leave links
to your [ __ ] products twitter's where
it's at it's good huh it's good it's
just hard to grow let's start selling
all my
my my lockwood gear right there too
[ __ ] comments i promise you you could
you could go to my lockwood page
it's um what you're wearing right here
yeah yeah
it's your brand or something yeah oh
good [ __ ] cause lockwood is
lockwood's school that jerome will say
he's like he's becoming
crazy to get out there to skate
sometimes oh well the reason why he said
it was crazy
you want to know why if you want to go
back to that photo of my uncle
my uncle that was mad dogging he's
the reason why we are all allowed to
skate lockwood
you weren't allowed to well he
it just wasn't skateable because a lot
of those guys were right there
oh god you gotcha it was filled with
gangsters
it was filled with fools but me and the
little squad that i had
we still pushed through it we still went
but we didn't go there like it was tough
we had to go like fight our way in and
sometimes we would just go and fight and
like and
get at these fools and they would come
and be like and just squandering around
us
like what's up man like uh hey
just uh they were they were they were
smoking pee dogs and and
and cocoa puffs and um they were
tripping man and they wanted to they
wanted to jack us
and i was like see you ain't jacking my
board like
that ain't that not today homie you
ain't jacking my board so a few of us
would just raise up and get our boards
and
we just [ __ ] square off with them
such a crazy environment to start
skating in man
until we became friends with them
and then i didn't tell them right away
hey my uncle is so and so
yeah i came home with a couple
dents and they were like man what
happened to you fool
i went to go skate lockwood whoa that's
my neighborhood what happened why why
you
i told my dad and he goes well i'm going
to talk to i'm going to talk to my
brother i'm going to talk to you know
his brother which
was sharp and he
went and got at his little homies and
straightened them out
and you know if my nephew comes here
with this homies to come skate
don't [ __ ] with them easy [ __ ]
request
hey these friends since then that was
like
back in the 90s early 90s and then since
then like
people had to go and like sneak in to
skate and if you got caught you got
caught
after that my uncle said that it was all
it was good bro
everybody could go there and skate and
now they would just come and join us and
we would kick you with us and we'd all
smoke together
yeah why not and then they would tell us
hey who could we jack fool
oh [ __ ] hey hey who here could be jack
and they were like hey what about that
white boy over there hey what's up will
we get him and i'll be like
i didn't even know that white boy and i
had no i don't even know him at all he
had a big old camera back in the day the
big old
cameras and i'm like nah for he's my
friend dog don't
don't mess with him don't mess with him
he's a friend of mine you know but he
wasn't really my friend he's helping him
but i just didn't want to get him jacked
and then he burned the spot out you know
yeah nobody wants to i would be like
don't trip man look like
um i would go to the trunk of our my
uh of my friend's car and i go get
product and give them stuff to
sell look don't just you don't need to
[ __ ]
jack these fools yeah here's some stuff
you can have oh that's cool dick
i got a shirt dick look they'll take it
off right there dig look at my shirt
dick
i got a skater shirt and they're just
like super happy
yeah like meshing worlds and the other
one's like not even fool you got one
let me get one dick i'm sorry now i
gotta give all the dicks one that's all
right
it's like a little passage of like yo
here rock that [ __ ] and it's [ __ ]
free promo
you see that gangbanger wearing a
[ __ ] plan you sure you're like what
the [ __ ] yeah
it's a different vibe man and and you
know
that's where i i learned the joke right
there i it was a
what do you what do you call a cholo
with one leg longer than the other
i don't know not even homes get the [ __ ]
at it yo
save that clip that's emoji [ __ ] right
there
oh my homie's gonna love that one that's
a good
um what about what you gotta call a
mexican with a rubber toe
roberto hey you've been there before got
it
uh-huh yeah you just [ __ ] you were in
the county jail with me when i said that
i made that up in the county a long time
ago fool that should spread like a wi-fi
i heard that one i think
i had to how the [ __ ] they get it um so
fabian underscore alamar on you said
tick tock yeah fabian underscore alamar
official fabian alamo official
on ig ig we'll we'll link everything
baby on facebook and you said lockwood
what's the website it's the oh there's
the website on the lockwood page
oh it's on the page yeah you got like
linked in the bio and yeah it's um
i'll give it to you guys it's um okay
yeah we'll link it in the description
too just to be safe yeah for sure
um yeah man and and i'm getting my brand
off real
soon man with the with everything that's
going on you know it's a
it's it's the the the link is
[Music]
www.lockwoodfath.com ath.com
yeah right there yeah that's it sick and
and i have like all these you see that
picture that first picture
that's what all those olive we're in
[ __ ] we're like emb right there i
believe we're in london or something
no [ __ ] that was our first menace ad
right there that's geno
keenan milton gino iannucci mike crum
jason dill and eric popecki and i'm the
one in the front i think you should
uh to a different country in that
section oh bro i've been all around the
world
london saying like okay skateboarding
sweden oh man
uh switzerland all over so sick
europe germany basketball scholarships
like you said getting your [ __ ] your
contract mexico
um it's it's been great uh
canada all over canada that's so tight
yeah
that's good [ __ ] man and i'm glad i'm
glad you have this new uh positive
yeah mindset that's good [ __ ] now it's
time to elevate it and let it go in five
years look back like look where i
started
how the [ __ ] we get here good [ __ ]
that's the whole plan man five year
plans are the best way to you know
i i gotta say i owe a lot of my success
to god right but
being here i have a lot of it
is to people like danny trejo
my manager bobby d
and um mario castillo like those guys
are
they that's the there's a lot of
different people that
that help you know i got a friend named
janet via
my parents everybody like all you know
everyone who's
who's been there for me and um
like a lot of different people have come
together you know even my
my boy todd shimabuku who helped me with
the
with the lockwood athletics you know
he's the guy who came to me and said hey
let's get this clothing line started and
let's do it i believe in you and i
i think you could hold it and do it
yourself and it's different positive
positive impacts yeah it changed your
life man
good job i got a lot of good things
going on and you know
hopefully uh you'll see me on the mayans
pretty soon too
oh that's why you said blasphemy not
watching minds nice
good [ __ ] that'd be tight i mean yeah
we'll see how that goes you know it'll
work out and
everything's going to come together you
know let's be positive dude yeah i got a
lot of good things coming and
and people helping me and like i said um
i i uh i want to do the stand-up thing
should i want to should the world's
opening back up yeah
it's a good angle man it's a it's a
different angle i just need a little
entire structure to get it tighten it up
and and to get
like a 10 minute 15 minutes it takes
time man it takes time but
work at it practice at it write five
minutes down do it for your homies
like hey that was funny like all right
cool that's not funny enough you guys
aren't dying laughing let me try again
yeah and it just takes not like skating
you're not gonna [ __ ] 360 flip your
first try
right it's not gonna happen man good
[ __ ] dude hey thank you i'm looking
forward to that good [ __ ] thank you for
coming
fabian almor if everybody wants to check
it out description below if you're on
spotify apple whatever
it's in the description everything all
his links everything thanks for stopping
by
appreciate it thank you brother all
right guys thank you we're going to get
out of here thank you for watching
another episode of dope as usual podcast
i'm dope ajola
have a dope ass day no weed i didn't
smoke weed at all it's crazy
damn some silver tip
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
perfect
[Music]
you